c'est le top départ pour la sixième
édition de la job academy lancée par la
fondation face yvelines dix demandeurs
d'emploi vont être mises en binôme avec
un professionnel du château de
versailles objectif retrouver une
employabilité à travers de l'ecoute du
soutien ou encore de l'accompagnement
c'est un contrat que l'on signe en trois
ou quatre mois avec apparat une fiole le
filleul s'engageant à rencontrer
régulièrement le para pour améliorer à
la fois son cv tous ces critères de
recherche
d'emploi des agents du château de
versailles de tous les secteurs de tous
les départements du château de
versailles qui vont dans trois mois
travailler avec eux pour
envisager leur nouvelle vie la vie
d'après la vie après une rupture une
secousse rendre son cv plus attractifs
ne pas perdre ses moyens pendant un
entretien s'y retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux les binômes se retrouveront au
minimum une fois tous les quinze jours
pendant trois mois pour différents
ateliers aujourd'hui c'était la première
rencontre entre francis et son parrain
il a 26 ans il sort des études
donc on va voir comment on peut me les
mes contacts en cybersécurité en
ingénierie informatique
et voir qu'est-ce qu'on pourra
travailler avec lui on va essayer déjà
de se présenter à l'oral
et de développer les compétences et ses
capacités il est très sympa donc en plus
ses hobbies correspond à roumieh donc on
a discuté en vue de discuter juste il ya
un instant j'espère que cette expérience
va me permettre d'avoir
un beau parcours professionnel
de messieurs professionnellement dans le
monde du travail également
bourgault ses compétences depuis 2000 15
71 personnes ont déjà été accompagnée
70% des personnes suivies retrouvent un
emploi après six mois cette année la
promotion vise les 100 %